Speaker 1: Let's go to Dario from Texas. Dario
from Texas, welcome. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hi, David. Oh, hello. Uh, so I'm
just kind of nervous. Okay, so my question,
it pertains to the debates about, like,
Trump's indictment and whether it's gonna
help. I just saw a recent poll from,
like, Rasmussen, I believe, that shows
Biden is trailing both Trump and to Sanders.
Speaker 1: So just so you know, Rasmussen's
not a good pollster, so I tend not to look at
Rasmussen. What I would do is maybe look at an
average of recent polls or look at like the
FiveThirtyEight recent polling and just look
at pollsters rated A and B, I just don't think
Rasmussen is a good pollster. But but it may
not matter for the question you're going to ask.
Speaker 2: Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. I don't want
to put like damage on a single poll noble anyways
when it comes to like, Trump's indictment. Yeah,
like. Like it could help him in a primary.
Blessed to have a hard time seeing how in
the general you know, like Trump, he needs
like, independents, right? And like moderate
Republicans, you know, to win the general, not
just to Maccabees. So my question to you is,
when it comes to the indictment, would actually
win over like independent swing voters were
could actually like hurt him in the general?
Speaker 1: I think in the general I don't
think the and so for now, we're talking just
about the one indictment. Right. If there's
a different indictment in Georgia, we would
have to evaluate the charges, the implications,
what that's going to do to Trump's ability
to campaign. And then I'll give you an
updated opinion based only on the arrest and
indictment in New York City with the 34 felonies,
I do believe it helps Trump in the primary.
It helps Trump because nobody's been talking
about Ron DeSantis since the Trump
arrest happened. And so publicity wise,
it's been better for Trump than DeSantis. I
think it is activated some of Trump's base.
And so I do think Trump is helped in the primary
by this New York City indictment. I don't think
it gets him a single new vote in the general.
And so there I think it actually hurts him.
Speaker 2: Oh, God. Okay. Yes. Yes. I was
only wondering because I remember during
during the during the during a like the 2016
election, like James Comey, like he released a
letter on like Hillary Clinton and like Hillary,
like she was never indicted. Never arrested. But
yet, you know, it didn't help her at all in the
general election. So so I'm just here wondering,
you know, Trump was actually indicted or
arrested and is likely to be indicted again
in future cases. I have a hard time, you
know, seeing how people outside America
base because it has like a W or go to trial, I.
Speaker 1: Agree with you 100%. And honestly,
if they really believed it was good,
they'd be less angry and they'd be
happier than they are. So I don't buy it for
a second. I think your analysis is spot on.
Speaker 2: Oh, gotcha. Okay. Yes. Like.
Like that's all I'm going to ask you. Like,
thank you for taking my call.
Speaker 1: All right, Dario from
Texas. Great to hear from you. We're going
to go to a break. I'm sorry I wasn't able
to get to everyone, but we will take calls
again. Back with much more right after this.